hey what's up everybody welcome back to
css3 in 30 days today's day number 21
and we're gonna be coding up some
animated CSS only spinners let's check
it out
animated spinners right here day number
21 we're gonna be making these right
here
spinners what would you use a spinner
for when you're loading content when
you're loading a page you know when
you're loading an application an image
that's where you'd use a spinner you see
it quite often in websites applications
software it's simply you're watching
videos even the spinner just indicates
that something is happening something is
loading and it's they're kind of
fascinating to look at and these are
only made in or these are made in css3
only so let's jump in and get started
here in our code editor we're gonna go
ahead and download day number 21
spinners
gonna give you a second to do that in
fact you could just pause the video go
ahead and do that and I'm just gonna
show you a couple things so here's the
index file HTML is very simple it's
simply a div with the class of spinner 1
and a div with the class of spinner too
that's it let's jump into our sandbox
and get coding our CSS first thing we're
going to do is we're going to select
spinner - 1 we're gonna give it a
position of relative display of inline
block vertical line of middle and now
we're going to give it a width 64 pixels
and height 64 pixels and a border radius
of 64 pixels could also say 100% that
should do the trick but 64 pixels means
it is going to be if the border raised
this border radius to 64 pixels and it's
the same as width and height then it's
gonna be a perfect circle all right if
we save that you probably shouldn't
actually see anything at this point you
just see an empty space that's 64 by 64
beauty now we're going to do is we're
going to say spinner - 1 and the before
pseudo-element
position:absolute we got to give it a
content of an empty string of course
and with whoops width of 64 pixels
height of 64 pixels and a border radius
again 64 pixels we're going to give it a
color of 3 to 3 and this is the text
color 3 to 3 be 40 but here's the thing
there's really no text but we're going
to be using an interesting CSS value
called current color it's kind of like a
CSS variable so watch this if I were to
go box-shadow:inset negative 5 pixels 0
0 and then 5 pixels and then current
color that's going to grab the actual
color so it's kind of like you set a
variable so I'm gonna save that check it
out in the browser you can see the
current color is that grey because it's
grabbing current color if I were to
remove this I'm not really sure what
would happen it looks like it would be
it's grabbing the text color its
inheriting the text color from the body
but if I were to change this to red the
current color should be red so that's
how that works right there pretty fun
little CSS trick there and now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna clip this
shape this unusual shape we just made to
a rectangle but we're going to actually
define the values here 0 64 pixels comma
32 pixels comma 0 that will give us this
shape here again kind of weird but hang
with me it's kind of like like a like an
8-bit hockey stick hanging upside down
but watch this we're gonna actually say
border-radius oh here's the problem oh
there we go border radius I thought I
already added that but I didn't do it
properly border 1864 so this hockey
stick shape is actually gonna now get
this shape here that looks a lot nicer
so you can see what the border radius
did to change that so this bore this
shape there without the border radius
actually kind of looks like it's very
unusual the right side of it is thicker
the top side of it is is a bit thinner
and long but the border radius really
gives it a nice
feel and you can almost see now how
that's gonna turn in you know how that's
going to look when we spin it so now
we're going to do is say animation we're
gonna give the animation name of rotate
horror one second infinitely linear and
in fact I want to ease it I think that
might be let's see what that looks like
and now we need to create a keyframe so
keyframes it's called rotator rotate
horror at 0% we're gonna say transform
and we're gonna rotate it 180 degrees
and let's say 50%
we're gonna go rotate to transform
whoops transform rotate back to zero
degrees and then 100% we're gonna do
back to 180 degrees let's see what that
does
interesting
very interesting
okay this the first one actually needs
to be negative 180 degrees but I'm gonna
try something here okay
so you see because I have an ease it's
actually doing this like jump jump jump
jump if I make it linear let's see if it
should just be spinning exactly but now
I'm wondering if I just started at zero
let's just try something start at zero
and I just say 100% we spent at 360 it
should still do the same thing yeah and
now I can do ease
I like that it's kind of neat so let's
try that okay
but now what I want to do is I wanted to
also animate the Box shadow and we're
going to say inset a negative five
pixels zero zero five pixels current
color that's in fact the same box
shadows right now but we need to set it
to this because what I want to do is now
make a very very it make a variation of
it so box shadow at okay this is where I
might need let's try this negative one
and then one let's see what that looks
like
very weird so here's where I'm going to
actually throw that 50% back in there
and I'm going to transform the whole
thing I'm gonna say 180 degrees here
starts at 0 to 180 degrees and then 360
and I'm going to do this box shadow at
50% I'm going to do this and then at
100% I'm going to go back to this
that should give me an interesting
effect
okay it does do something it's kind of
like it we're doing some weird stuff
here folks we're gonna change this back
to linear and that should probably mean
there we go so there we go so you see
how as it goes around it gets thinner
and then thicker thinner and thicker
it's kind of neat it looks like a
tadpole
in a way now I don't like how it's thin
on the side I kinda want to get thin at
the top so that's where I'm gonna go
back here at the zero-percent I'm gonna
say negative 180 degrees to start at
then it's gonna go spin to zero degrees
at the top which will make it thin at
the top and then I'm gonna bring it to
180 degrees here that is gonna change
where it gets smaller at the top yep I
like that
that looks good there's our first
rotator now let's go down to the next
spinner so I'm going to leave the
keyframes at the bottom good practice to
do that so your code is organized the
next spinner is gonna be called or is
called spinner - to position relative
margin 32 all around and
display:inline-block
vertical-align:middle same styles as the
top excuse me the top one those first
four lines 16 pixels width 16 pixels
height and then we're going to do border
radius this is where I had the problem
last time I just wrote a border instead
of border radius 16 pixels background
color
three-two-three b40 cool and now we're
gonna save that and see if it does
anything okay I call silly Brad I said
spinner one you probably caught that
spinner - there we go so we have a dot
we have a nice circle let's continue now
I'm gonna say spinner - - before
pseudo-element and spinner - - after
pseudo-element
position:absolute display inline block
vertical-align:middle height 16 pixels
width 16 pixels border radius 16 pixels
background color inherit content of
course we need the content I'm gonna put
that at the top I like it having right
after position there we go
and that's going to you're not gonna see
anything it's just creating the the
sizes of the elements I don't think
you're actually gonna see it in fact no
we don't see anything yet and we don't
see anything yet because the position is
absolute and we haven't given it any
left or right we haven't transformed it
or moved it along the x axes at all so
it's actually just hiding behind this
circle so they are they're just hiding
so that's where we're actually going to
start animating so now I'm gonna say
spinner - - before I'm gonna animate the
before circle and I'm gonna say
transform and we're gonna go translate X
and that's going we're gonna bring 120%
that way so negative 120%
and so let's save that and cool okay so
now what we're gonna do is we're gonna
say transform origin so this lets you
modify the origin for transformation so
you can transform you can move where the
origin of the element is so meaning like
are you transforming from the center the
top left the top right or any anywhere
around the element itself you could see
bottom center left top right you can
actually use numeric values as well so
let's go 32 pixels and so that's X and
then Y which is gonna be important once
we start our animation so we're gonna
call the first animation orbit - one
over one second though let's do it
infinite and linear to keep it safe and
now we need to create that animation
keyframe do it down here at the bottom
keyframes and let's call it what we said
we would orbit one zero percent we're
going to say transform translate X we're
gonna go we're gonna start at negative
120% and we're gonna rotate it 180
degrees so add zero percent that's its
first step in the timeline then at let's
do
thirty percent of the way through let's
change the rotate to zero degrees and
leave the translate at they went
negative 120 we're going to 70% the
translate will remain the same and the
rotate will stay at zero in fact we're
gonna leave it there for for that
portion as well and then one more hair
translate X we're gonna go to negative
180 degrees let's see what we just
created okay interesting not quite where
we're trying to get as you can see here
this is kind of more what we're trying
to get to so we got our orbit one
infinite linear and what did we do 30 70
oh that's the problem
100% we're gonna bring it back around so
now let's save that there we go so it
swings around and it goes as you could
see you see how it swings wide out here
the reason why it does that is because
this is where you can see this coming
into play the transform origin if I take
this out and save it watch what's gonna
happen back the transform or it doesn't
even do anything let's say 10 pixels 10
pixels just to okay you see how that's
working transfer needs a transform
origin in order to for us to animate
that transform if I just left it at
nothing it's actually it is actually
rotating but you can't see it rotate
because it's just a black circle so you
know you can't actually see that it's
working so we actually do have to have a
transform origin if I did 10 pixels and
10 pixels on the X&Y it's going from top
and left so it's gonna be rotating
around that that point so there's
actually a timpanist net timpanist net I
don't really know how to pronounce that
great website though you could see the
transform origin by default is Center
Center you can go you can go top center
you can go bottom center and you can do
specific points like we did 10 pixels
and 10 pixels and it will rotate it
based on that point as if you put a pin
in in an object and then you spun it
around that pin so that's kind of what
we're doing here so we want to go back
to our 32
ooh pixels and 50% and that's going to
allow it to spin on a very unusual axis
so that it creates that effect okay so
that means we are now on to the next one
so let's style the after pseudo-element
spinner - - after and what we're gonna
do here is we're simply let's copy this
one and just change a few the values
just to save some typing transform what
we're gonna make this one 120% so it's
on the other side this is going to be
1/2 16 pixel and negative 16 pixels and
50% so that when it spins around it's
going to do the opposite effect and we
can't use orbit 1 because it's gonna do
it's gonna do that which is really weird
unusual stuff we're creating here so we
need to create an orbit - and do the
invert inverted version of orbit 1 so
copy that paste it out we're gonna call
it orbit 2 and we're gonna start at
instead of the negative values all just
going to be inverted so if it's a
negative it's a positive it's a positive
it's a negative so negative 120 now
becomes 120 180 now becomes negative 180
like so so now this would be positive
and leave those there that should do
that should do the trick I might have I
might I'll see
okay so now I don't want them to do that
it's actually they're just like I like
doing like a big like high-fives or
something let's make this one negative
180 there mmm odd
okay
spinning
I like this that we're trying to figure
this out together figure out some
problems together
I at this present moment I'm trying to
understand why it did it's doing this
that is very odd
let's take Kane let's take out orbit - I
just want to see what orbit one is doing
or what one is doing what we want yes
orbit two
is it start hora - okay wait wait let's
wrote no cake I was wrong when they said
switch all the values to negative and
positive the translate needs to switch
so that now orbit 2 is all positive
values but output here we started like
this we have the rotates we're gonna
rotate at the exact same just from the
different side awesome and there they
are spinning in the proper direction and
we have example or 1 swirling around
shrinking as it gets to the top that
looks awesome so there we go we've got
our CSS only spinners that are animating
and that's just a couple examples you
can literally create whatever you want
as a spinner maybe how about this
challenge for you create a third example
a third spinner and make it literally
whatever you want it could be a spinning
square it could be three spinning
squares it could be something that's
bouncing across the screen you could you
could do whatever you want for a spinner
it could be very simple very complex
very unusual you could combine these
animations and do something very very
quirky totally up to you so try that out
exercise some CSS transforms and
keyframes and animations and see what
you can come up with thanks for joining
me today on day number 21 see it
tomorrow and day number 22
[Music]